tô aqui hoje para falar com o coração
na verdade não tem outra forma para
falar como eu fui apresentada soldado
rolando a sua do complexo da maré
é bom né gente e eu quero contar um
pouco da minha história pra vocês pra
gente conseguir viajar junto assim do
que eu entendo como uma proposta da
universidade de universidade que eu
quero para o meu filho quando era
pequena volta de 78 anos
meus pais eles precisavam trabalhar e
meu pai ele muito corajoso ele trocou
meio barraco que estava tudo pronto por
um barraco de madeira em uma outra rua
porque a expectativa dele é sempre
construir alguma coisa que pudesse dar
conta dos filhos nem ele queria ter dois
e aí nesse ato de coragem
ele precisava da ajuda da família é pra
fazer isso acontecer
foi um momento que eu me vi com 78 anos
a minha posição era de mesmo que
inconsciente ajudar né
e aí eu lembro que os dois saíam para
trabalhar ea mãe trabalhava na uerj meu
pai sempre trabalhou aqui na ufrj e era
uma honra orgulho minha mãe trabalha na
uerj é acho que até mentia sobre o cargo
dela era encarregada da faxina não era
nem a faxineira vai encarregar um cargo
de chefia
o meu pai era um chery fu é presidente
da comissão responsável pelo património
isso é uma tentação para mim né e
precisava ficar sozinha em casa eu acho
que eu não lembro de ter ficado muito
tempo mas houve um período da minha vida
que eu precisava ficar sozinha em casa e
na minha comunidade tinha uma na minha
favela tinha um serviço de
a associação de moradores que gera
telefone a gente ligava para esse
telefone e quando chegar aí a atendente
chamava a gente no alto falante e aí
minha mãe ligava de cinco minutos para
saber como eu estava
e aí eu lá na minha saía de casa e
atendi o telefone está tudo bem
como é que está óptimo casa não tive que
sair para atender você e aí eu acho que
com essa experiência eu consegui
perceber ao longo da minha vida como é
crescer em comunidade porque não era
fácil pro meu pai minha mãe sai de casa
deixa uma filha de oito anos por essa
idade em casa sozinha para empreender um
sonho que era comum da família sem que
ele tivesse a ajuda de vizinhos de
terezinha
você pode olhar se acontecer alguma
coisa vocês ocorre ela a é da minha tia
que morava do outro lado da rua da leila
dos vizinhos ali e o meu contato com a
universidade foi nesse contexto de deter
estes dois quais trabalhadores de
espaços universidade que nos momentos
que precisava eu acabava caindo
acompanhando eles a ufrj ela sempre foi
um propósito na minha vida
por conta disso diferente dos meus
primos por exemplo que alguns nem tendem
ainda o que é esse espaço
eu fui crescendo dentro desse contexto
legal tive meus pais que trabalharam
para que eu chegasse aqui esse
privilégio na favela
não é qualquer pessoa que tem essa
família que tem acho que não só não só
na favela mas acho que num na nossa
sociedade né que tem uma família que
ampara
e que ajuda mesmo dentro de uma
dificuldade e que estaria disposto a
fazer você crescer dentro daquele
propósito do que você entende que é o
melhor e eu fui comecei a procurar
comecei a crescer nesse sonho de acessar
a universidade já era dado àquela casa
estava sendo construída para uma filha
que ia ser na universidade e que ia
aprender e que ia a é trazer orgulho e
que ia acontecer
diferente das estatísticas diferente dos
primos e essa é a primeira universitária
avançando construído país e quando
cheguei aqui falei pra bem disso o
nervosismo
passei no lar a e sofrendo com aquela
situação de pós greve tudo fechado não
tinha como ter certeza se tinha passado
no meio digital
e eu falei pronto cheguei na
universidade open agora
agora é só estudar que você o que eu
quero ser só que não
no meio desse processo é engravidei
legal né
só que não também nesse processo de
nessa nossa questão da gravidez é uma
das primeiras 12 primeiro nas minhas
primeiras ações foi chegar
bruno coordenador de curso e dizer tocar
aqui você pode fazer pra me adiantar
aí ele falou assim nada obra assim eu
queria puxar algumas matérias aqui pra
gente para me dedicar para acertar a
faculdade estava só que aí ele falou
assim bosco fez uma besteira né
[Música]
caraca você não sabe que isso não é hora
de gravar está revoltada com a vida eu
desculpa mas a gente está discutindo a
minha vida de aí ele falou assim para
mim olha é mas foi uma besteira mas tem
que admitir mas está insistindo né
aí virou e falou assim eu falei tá mas
não tem uma solução já que vocês acham
que é uma mistura partindo desse
princípio não tem uma solução daqui eu
escolhi a vida minha você pode me ajudar
alguma coisa eles solução tem é só você
querer isso com quatro meses
gente eu me afastei lei como assim
não sei bem o que esse cara tá me
propondo a ser invasivo e fazer escroto
machista ameaça dar certo tudo que eu
não precisava agora e é isso aí na
universidade no branco não porque eu
precisava da bolsa ainda estava lá e
descobre que conseguirá continuar na
bolsa não estava lá e aí meu filho
nasceu e eu me separei as nesse processo
nesse período me separei e pronto me vi
sozinha com o filho com uma universidade
para uma faculdade para terminar e ainda
era um sonho e só foi implantado é um
sonho não é um sonho de raiz não era um
sonho só eu foi um sonho construído
junto com a família então eu tinha que
tenho que fazer isso ainda toda a
gravação ainda e aí foi quando pensei
olha vou ter que dar um jeito nisso
vamos vender doces na rua que não fazia
o menor sentido pra mim vendeu doce
sozinha não tem nenhuma empatia com a
dor de uma outra humana que passa a
mesma coisa do que eu simplesmente por
vender eu falei olha então a gente vai
ter que tirar alguma coisa que atenda
não só a minha necessidade mas também
necessidade de outras mulheres
e foi aí que eu criei as dicas e as
dicas ela é um
um fã ela é um empreendimento um
coletivo ainda tem a informação que é
pra mulheres sobretudo mães de favela
que pretende criar uma rede colaborativa
de geração de renda
essa geração de renda é justamente pra
você poder conciliar sonhos
nenhuma mãe precisa sair da universidade
para ter um pra garantir coisas básicas
por seu filho a gente pode trabalhar
junto a gente pode criar uma creche
parental
a gente pode fazer as coisas acontecerem
daqui porque a gente não tem a cor da
universidade não tem uma creche na
universidade
a gente não tem nenhum nenhuma base ali
pra atender às nossas necessidades e
como eu estava mais afastado da
universidade no ano eu não tinha
proposto a universidade porque eu nunca
entendi a universidade como espaços de
de propor alguma coisa
e com essa ideia de comunidade que eu
tenho que a comunidade me fez
então acredito que a gente muda o mundo
a partir da comunidade a partir do
conceito de comunidade não é uma unidade
comum que cria empatia e aí consegue
sensibilizar pela do outro enquanto a
gente não se organizar dessa forma a dor
do outro sempre vai ser do que eu digo
isso porque antes de eu ter filho eu não
conseguia perceber a necessidade ou a
falta de um fraldário no banheiro
feminino de uma universidade ou de
qualquer outro lugar
enquanto isso faz diferença a dona era
minha
sáb e dom
como você se sensibiliza pela do outro
quando você mesmo não sendo não sentindo
essa dor
você cria essa empatia e eu acredito que
essa empatia se cria quando você se
aproxima e como você se aproxima
quando você está nesse contexto de
comunidade
sabia que minha mãe precisava de alguma
ajuda e para assegurar a chave da casa
para me olhar
ela estava perto ela tava ali junto ou
pelo menos sensível à causa e aí nesse
nesse processo diferente está da
primeira palestrante acho que houve
melhora vanessa ela estava falando que
ela não teve amigos na universidade que
acolher cela
eu tenho um diferencial em relação a ela
que esses meus amigos da universidade
entenderam a necessidade dessa
comunidade e eu tenho uma compreensão
agora muito grande sobre a minha
condição mas é o que eu acho que é o que
a ufrj pode fazer quando fala da ufrj
isso foi algumas discussões que eu tive
com meu corpo dor com guilherme está
falando de pessoas e sim dá pra mudar de
baixo para cima a partir de
reivindicações a partir do censo de de
comunidade é a base de sensibilidade
a gente consegue mudar alguma coisa
assim e o que eu entendo o que eu acho
que o hrj pode fazer enquanto pessoa é
tá tento a esses detalhes e quando fala
de pessoas ou de vocês que eu consigo
ver aqui todo mundo que está aqui né que
é exposto pelo menos a gente não vai
conseguir dar conta de tudo
a gente vai conseguir dar conta de todas
as demandas dos outros mas está disposto
pelo menos a perceber que a dor do outro
é importante conta sua e que sim
quando você entende isso
vocês conseguem mudar sabe agora eu tô
no curso de história da arte ainda e
esse curso de história da arte ele está
sendo coordenado por uma mulher mãe que
entende todas as essas complexidades da
maternagem barra maternidade e você vê
que é uma outra você percebe assim é uma
outra ideia de de curso de gestão
quando você se propõe a pelo menos
entender o que o outro sente se eu não
sou especialista de nada
espero ser um dia mas eu falo de uma
experiência dolorosa porque assim eu tô
aqui mas tem milhões de irmãos meus de
cria da nova holanda que não sabe o que
é nesse lugar que não sabe o que ele
pode fazer pra tá nesse lugar que a
gente tem uma universidade estou falando
de pessoas de novo que está
completamente comprometida com esse
perfil que não está disposta a propor
alguma discussão que agrega esse cara
porque pra eu tá aqui eu entrei no
perfil
eu passo batido a gente se eu disser que
eu moro
sei lá no botafogo todos vocês vão
acreditar
sáb então assim o que eu acho
é a gente precisa criar e se essa
diferença o conceito de comunidade se
sensibilizar pela dor do outro
se se posicionar sim para discutir a
educação de base para que esse cara no
perfil dele chega aqui que ele não
precisa se moldar entrar dentro de um
padrão para o ataque e sempre se
sensibilizado pela vida do outro
uma das coisas que não podia deixar de
falar e que insistiu o tempo todo é que
eu sou eu sou mãe hannah da sua mulher
de amor em costa barros costa barros e
isso me faz mais fácil ainda este
complexo do chapadão
meu filho nasceu lá e mudando um
pouquinho a ordem das coisas
a universidade que eu quero meu filho é
uma universidade que aceite esse cara
está ligado
são esses caras roberto pleito
o sling eo wilson são esses caras que
foram mortos com 111 tiro de bala
perdida que vai fazer uma universidade
que eu quero para o meu filho
a gente não pode ignorar isso
cinco mães que perderam seus filhos ali
nós somos uma universidade parte da
sociedade ea universidade que eu quero
que o meu filho é uma universidade que
ele esteja aqui e não ali eu não quero
chorar mais por um irmão
eu não quero chorar mais por um com uma
mãe porque a universidade que eu quero
a universidade que esteja disposta a
discutir a relação desses caras
a gente também fica ele é palestrante
também já então faz sentido falar então
assim é isso que eu quero que eu queria
dividir com vocês
a universidade que eu quero pros meus
filhos é uma universidade 5º ano os
perfis
a universidade que se sensibilize a uma
universidade que esteja disposta pelo
menos discutir essa questão e eu falo de
pessoas
sou eu e só você e todo mundo
essa universidade que eu quero pra ele
[Aplausos]